Je ne peux pas payer le loyer avec les choses une fois une
citrouille et ce sont des gardiens,
ils ne valent pas la peine
à Asgard ces pièces ces pièces
valent un gazillion de dollars humains d'accord
il y a un gazillion que vous êtes riche
qui fait parce que oh non  on va
échanger l'aller au marché créer un
magasin nous et oui ouais Asgardian où
auparavant appartenait à quatre je suis une célébrité
qui se vendra comme des petits pains vous devrez peut-
être penser à obtenir un
emploi ouais ouais j'ai un travail  non mon boulot
c'est que j'ai sauvé la planète mais peut-être que
tu devrais trouver un
boulot  un muscle et
c'est le muscle et c'est un muscle
là vous êtes tous des muscles c'est tout un
muscle donc je suis couvert de cerveaux et
j'ai plus de cerveaux que vous alors
pensez-vous que nous pourrions simplement penser que nous
devons le servir je ne  Je ne pense pas que nous pouvons
obtenir un chirurgien  n obtenir un serveur que nous pouvons aujourd'hui,
nous n'avons pas obtenu également un serveur
Marvel's Doctor Strange en numérique en
blu-ray
[Musique]